the cdc study shows the overwhelming
majority of people
who are getting infected with
coronavirus are wearing the masks always
or often again that's not saying
anything about the masks
per se just telling you how this virus
is actually spreading
in reality well we see the same thing in
chicago right now they did a survey
in chicago of how many residents
who sent blood spot samples to
northwestern university researchers
tested positive for covid antibodies
so they had people sort of send in these
samples and they're going to see
not even just how many people have the
virus currently but how many people have
the antibodies so
they had the virus in the past do you
know how many chicagoans
have had coronavirus according to this
survey
one in five a full 20
of chicagoans who sent in these samples
have had coronavirus this was my point
when when we were talking earlier
i've been reiterating this almost once a
week now the liberals think that
conservatives oppose all of their kind
of crazy measures
to stop the spread of coronavirus
because we think we're never going to
get coronavirus but
actually the opposite is true we oppose
them
well one because there is some dispute
over the efficacy of some of these
measures
two now in the case of the lockdowns the
world health organization is actively
saying don't do the lockdowns the
lockdown's very bad for you
but disputes about the efficacy of these
things aside
the reason that we are not
indulging this sort of thing and
clamoring to throw the world into a
global economy or into a global economic
depression over the coronavirus measures
is because not that we think we won't
get it but because we know
kovid's here to stay we're very likely
going to get it
w.h.o came out the other day and said
one in 10 people on earth
has gotten coronavirus 10 of the entire
world population
has gotten this virus in the 9 or 10
months that it has
existed it's not going to stop there
folks
it's gonna keep spreading one in five
chicagoans has had coronavirus
i know you think that you can protect
yourself from that forever
because there's some government policy
some matter of social engineering that's
gonna protect you from germs that now
we're on a
a political crusade to defeat
germs you're not going to do it it's not
going to happen folks
this is this is not only as foolish as
say the war on poverty you know
with a war on this or the war on that
this is more foolish
you will not defeat disease you can
improve health
you can mitigate disease you can develop
vaccines that have certain efficacy
great i encourage everybody to do that
you will not eliminate disease from the
world you will not
bring your risk down to zero percent
which is what i think our utopian
friends
on the progressive left think that
they're going to do
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you